el día transcrido con mucha tranquilidad
no ha habido escenas de violencia que se
tenían Eso sí ha habido más de 620
pequeños delitos electorales personas
que han destrozado una urna han
intentado pegar los botones de la urna
ha habido incluso más de 200 arrestados
pero no ha sido nada grave la gran
imagen del día son las colas en muchos
colegios electorales en varios puntos
del país sin embargo el Tribunal
Superior electoral no sabe ni ser
todavía si es porque ha bajado la
obtención que en 2018 tuvo 30 millones
de personas que renunciaron a dar su
voto o si se debe un nuevo sistema de
biometría implantado en los últimos años
que puede haber ralentizado a partir de
ahora se van a cerrar los colegios y con
las urnas electrónicas se deberían
conocer en pocas horas los resultados
incluso es posible que este año se
conozcan antes porque por primera vez en
todo Brasil se vota siguiendo el horario
de Brasilia hay que recordar que hay
cuatro usos y se ha organizado la
votación para que acabe en todo el país
ahora en este Exacto momento Y Valeria a
la espera de conocer como nos contaba
los resultados en el centro del país en
Brasil que se sabe del voto en el
exterior
por primera vez hay
de estos que viven de brasileños que
viven
en el de 700.000 y de momento Lula está
ganando en muchos más países le hemos
visto ganando en Francia en la Oceanía
Nueva Zelanda Australia china pero
también en países inesperados Como por
ejemplo Rusia y Hungría de momento hasta
ahora se sabe que bolsonaro ganó en
Japón y en Israel y que Lula ganó en
Palestina Esos son los datos parciales
hasta ahora veremos de aquí en las
próximas horas Cuáles son los resultados
definitivos